[Music]
every year at CES were used to LG and
Samsung battling it out at the realm of
televisions but in the past few years a
new battle is taking shape and that is
in the realm of refrigerators let's take
a look at two of the most awesome
refrigerators you have ever seen I'm
here in front of my favorite fridge is
the LG Smart interview you can surf the
web on it this is sort of an opaque
screen like translucent but you can see
through it to the food inside of it but
you can also surf the internet on it
nice full screen view great
responsiveness their runs webOS it has
panoramic camera inside of it that you
can check on your phone when you go to
the store and you just need to know
what's in your fridge and what to buy
this is Samsung's family hub 2.0 like
last year they had touchscreen Tizen
based fridge but they just had one of
them now they're expanding the range
there's a they're French door models
will all be available with this big
touchscreen and the family of 2.0
interface there are cameras in here with
those do and they take pictures of your
food and they let you know if you're
running out of stuff if this while
you're at the store they also have the
ability this year to marriage stuff on
your TV so you can actually watch TV on
your fridge the other thing they're
stream Pandora as well the big addition
this year is that it's also voice
controlled so you can talk to your
fridge now you can ask you to do things
like scream Pandora if your hands are
full like cake batter you can ask it to
read out recipes and that kind of thing
full web connectivity this is definitely
toe-to-toe among the best fridges we've
ever seen and what's happening this year
is that some of these features that were
you know prototypes or crazy ideas these
are actually becoming more mainstream
stamps
doing it LG is doing it I'm sure a lot
of other companies are going to be doing
it so it might seem far-fetched right
now five years your fridge all fridges
might happen
[Music]